[Music]
[Applause]
if i were a star college basketball
player i would least like to be drafted
by orlando houston sacramento
or the knicks
or other
let me start with tim legler with that
question the espn nba analyst and then
one of the great shooters in nba history
hate to go negative to start out here
legs but would you rather be
the team that you would least likely to
be drafted by or want to be drafted by
orlando houston sacramento or the knicks
i would say the kings
i didn't take long to get that in but
you did
um i i i just think you know i just
think look at the track record of of the
organization and the track record of
guys that they've dropped drafted at the
top of the lottery i mean number one
they don't seem to really develop there
and two they don't seem to stay there
very long so if i were a top pick
rather than maybe have a few wasted
years at the beginning of my career
uh maybe you'd be better off in a
healthier organization because they just
they've had a very difficult time
getting anything right
we would look at drafts sometimes and
you wouldn't take the best player you
would take the player that you thought
was best for you and teams may you know
the draft is littered with teams who
made these mistakes where you go we got
to go get a big guy wait but michael
jordan's nope you got to go after a big
guy there but i wonder about today's nba
chad holmgren is a big guy
but he's not that prototypical big guy
down low so if you're looking at orlando
uh would you buy into chet holmgren with
the uh you know limited sample size we
saw at gonzaga
yeah i would i i've seen him play enough
to look at the skill set there dan i
mean this this guy's a special talent
now obviously that body type has got to
change a little bit but you know you
look at kevin durant coming out i know
they're different players and kevin
rant's one of the greatest scorers this
league's ever seen so that's not
necessarily a comparison
but what i'm saying is the body type
kevin rant never really did develop he
clearly got stronger to play through
contact than he did when he in his first
few years the league you could ride his
hip and not come off balance and he was
an inefficient player early on and he
was able to get stronger functionally to
play through it chad holmgren absolutely
needs to add some weight some bulk some
strength but when you look at him and
handle the ball in the open floor and
you look at his vision and passing
ability and his ability to step out and
shoot and probably for me the real
differentiating factor would be
the ground this guy covers defensively i
mean he is an elite level
weak side defender at what's probably
going to end up being a small forward
position
this is one of the best rim protecting
small forwards we've ever seen come into
this league with the ground he covers
and his instincts for being there at the
right time so you add all that up i
think chet holmgren it's going to take
it's going to take some time you got to
be patient because the guy can't weigh
more than 180 pounds i'd be shocked if
he weighs more than that you're going to
have to develop that body but the skill
set man is special i like how he's a
seven footer and we're talking about him
being a small forward we got to get rid
of these labels legs i talked about this
yesterday nobody is mentioning lebron
james is the greatest point guard of all
time or second to magic
like we when we talk point guards would
be like well you got to put chris paul
and you got koozie and nash and stockton
and
why why isn't lebron the greatest point
guard or luca right now he's a point
guard but we don't
you know we don't call them that why
you're dead on we don't and i'm as
guilty as anybody i should do it because
i've been referring to lebron james as a
point guard for a decade i mean that's
really what he is let's be honest about
it the guy initiates every possession
when he's on the floor well isn't that
what a point guard the way we used to
know it you know what that means lead
guard point guard whatever you want to
call it luca dance it's the same thing
you're 100 right we just we don't
because of the size of these players and
they're just not prototypical what we
think that's supposed to look like but
there's no question and right now in
today's game um there is not a player in
the league that controls possessions to
a greater extent than luca doncic and
that to me is the essence of what a
point guard is we'll talk about that
series coming up in a moment talking to
tim lager legler espn nba analyst
there's certain players who get to the
postseason and become different players
i know that you you know michael jordan
and you know some of these players but
like reggie miller was a different
player in the postseason jimmy butler
tim duncan different player in the
postseason what is it about those
players
that it just bigger the game the bigger
the moment for them the bigger the
performance yeah i completely agree with
those guys and jimmy butler is
fascinating because
to me
i mean there's such an incredible leap
that he takes in terms of his
focus and his
competitiveness almost i i've described
him often as
the greatest boring player i've ever
watched in my life right because he
doesn't do
any of the stuff that wow
he's a guy that's going to operate
mainly in the mid-range area of the
floor he's going to get to the line a
lot that's not exactly exciting i mean
he d's up when it's this time of the
year but he's not doing those things
that are the eye candy that we love to
watch like some of these other great
players in the league are he's so
methodical about it but clearly and eric
spoelstra alluded to this last night
there's something about
got certain guys
that it they really only get the hair on
their neck up when something's dramatic
is on the line and that's the case
obviously in the postseason and he was
spectacular last night and he completely
took over that game in the third quarter
really on both ends of the floor and
gave them a 1-0 lead in a series i
picked boston to win but of course i
didn't know horford and smart were going
to be out so we'll see how it goes now
those guys don't play in game two when
they go down 2-0
beating a team that's that well coach
that's that good defensively four out of
five is going to be tough a tall order
for boston i had to laugh that uh your
uh fellow espner jay williams said that
you know we have slighted the miami heat
and i wanted to say to jay your network
slighted the miami heat because you guys
spent an entire year talking about the
lakers and the brooklyn nets
miami heat we're the best team record
wide wise in the east
but there's no drama there there's no
click bait there i mean that's how we
cover sports now where you go
we've probably talked more about the
lakers now and they've been out of the
postseason then we have been the miami
heat in the postseason
no it's a great call and you know and
when they made the changes in the
offseason i i thought the miami heat had
a great chance to get to the finals
because they added pj talk or kyle out
right so all that playoff experience of
lowry the toughness of pj tucker likes
things that they needed
but here's why when you look at the
other teams that we're talking about all
the time in the east it's because of
what i just said
they've got the eye candy players
they've got giannis they've got embiid
and hardin they've got durant and kyrie
they've got jason tatum
nobody on miami really looks like that
even though jimmy ball is a great player
bam adebayo is a
an all-star one of the best uh defensive
centers in the league one of the most
versatile big guys in the league
they don't do the things that tantalize
us that make us want to talk about them
every night so instead and i think eric
spoelstra is perfectly fine with that
let's just show up every day be
professional about what we do end up
with the number one seed and and be
incredibly difficult to operate against
in those moments and that's exactly what
they did last night it was very
impressive the way they turned it up
against them coming out of the locker
room
i'm curious the uh
gamesmanship the game of verbal ping
pong with luca and draymond green
verbal bouquets right now
everybody i you know draymond is one of
my favorite players love the way he
plays uh luke is unbelievable he's
unstoppable
how long does this last tim
i would say probably within the first
eight seconds of the game there's going
to be some sort of
of a verbal back and forth uh the first
time luca you know goes goes into the
lane and tries to back somebody down and
throws his arms into somebody gets a
call draymond will immediately start in
and at no point over the next six or
seven games however long it lasts will
draymond stop talking about what luke is
doing and vice versa you know this is
going to be fascinating because there is
a there is a whole other layer to luca
that has to just drive players insane
and it's the constant smiling
the grinning
the the look on his face of
man am i having fun out here and god is
this easy
and
i mean what what drives and think about
it dan i was thinking about the other
day when he was doing it to booker
in that game and it started off he was
doing it by the way not when they were
up 40. he hit his first two threes of
the game and he was grinning like that
he knew something right that nobody else
knew in that moment which is i am in a
great place right now mentally and i am
by far the best player on the floor
we're going to be just fine but i was
thinking imagine
anything you did competitively in your
life right you go play golf with three
of your buddies and
every shot a guy hits for four hours
he's laughing
and you know you can't beat him or
you're you're in a boxing match and a
guy's tuning you up and then steps back
between jabs it just grins at you like
what could get under your skin more and
that's what luca is doing to people
right now and it's going to get chippy
physical whatever however you want to
describe it the bottom line is i don't
think anybody is capable of getting this
guy off his game he the pace he plays
with his physical strength the way he
anticipates what's coming his way
i i just don't think he's affected by
anything that's in front of him he is so
unique and so fascinating because of it
it would bother me more
if a guy just grinned as opposed to
smack talk
like like i agree right
like that that's gonna hurt when you
laugh you're you're laughing at me like
if you want to go back and forth and we
exchange words that's one thing but when
you're just laughing you don't have to
say a word
oh man because booker is just
he's not even making eye contact he's
just staring straight ahead and luke is
like looking up at him like hey you know
you mad bro
it's just that picture is i mean that
picture
it did make me laugh out loud just
because the nature of he's looking up
like he literally if i could put a
thought bubble on luka doctor took that
moment it looked like he was saying
it's gonna be okay little buddy you'll
be all right
you'll get one to drop don't worry keep
trying and then if he makes one
literally he's at the point almost
where in that game he was going to be
like there you go right see it's fun
making shots when it goes in it's a lot
more fun like it i just can't think of
anything more going at one point he went
in there he got hit converted
and literally
was smiling and it took his hands and
kind of like rubbed his hands through
his hair like a model and i'm going
what is happening out here and so
uh
look and look he is he is special
obviously obviously this guy is
something else man and i i think dan
halfway through his rookie year i
described him in this way larry bird is
my favorite athlete of all time and i
said
this guy kind of reminds me of bird but
with a better handle and a quicker first
step
but think about that combination that's
kind of what we have he's got the nerve
he's got the you know he's not as pure
as shooter as bird but in some ways more
lethal because he can string together
shots from deep you know off the dribble
that larry really didn't do um
and and so for me the iq obviously the
passing ability he's incredible and
that's why i think dallas has a
legitimate shot in the series i'm
picking golden state to win the series
but this is not going to be easy yeah
i've mentioned this before there's
certain players and i liken them to if
we were going to attach music to their
game it's jazz there's a jazz feel to
kawhi leonard that he just moves at his
own pace and and the same with luca in a
in a sport where athleticism is always
on display
with speed being able to jump quickness
they they get to where they need to go
you know where they're going to go
but you can't stop them
it's just one of those weird dynamics
about basketball that i don't know if
you can explain
certain players being able to do it in a
certain way at their own speed
yeah completely and you know i've
watched some of the guys guarding him
right now i mean look at mikael bridges
he was runner-up for defensive player of
the year the guy's got you know he's got
seven two wingspan he's six eight he's
committed to it
and
he had no he had no ability physically
to to dictate anything to luka doncic
like the great defensive players in this
league typically the reason that we talk
about him in that vein dan is because
they dictate terms to a certain extent
now look you're going to have great
players make shots on guys but over the
course of 48 minutes
they are dictating what they're going to
allow you to do because they're that
strong they're that quick they're that
relentless
and bridges wasn't able to really do any
of that to luca doncic and look draymond
green is is not going to get a ton of
him he'll get him on some switches this
is going to be more about klay thompson
and andrew wiggins than anything else
because they've got the size length
strength but when you watch what luca's
about to do to those guys he hits him
with that shoulder on the back down he
knocks you backwards and then he spins
away to get to that fadeaway there's
just not a lot you can do and if you
want to run somebody at him okay here
comes dorian finney smith and bullock
and jalen brunson and bertons and all
these guys clibba
and they can make 18 threes in the game
that's why it's gonna be fascinating to
me the number one thing i'm looking for
tonight is what not not the initial
coverage what does steve kerr do as the
game progresses as the series progresses
to mix up coverages on him because you
cannot give him a steady dose of
anything in one game because that's the
formula for disaster for golden state
always great to catch up with your legs
thanks for joining us
anytime dave
it's tim legler espn nba analyst knows a
thing or two about shooting we have our
play of the day coming up and we'll
settle on our poll question we're back
after this dan patrick show